[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRUNO AZIZA: Welcome to another
episode of "Data Journeys."
I'm Bruno Aziza, and I'm
excited to be here today
with Bob from Geotab.
And so we're going
to learn from him
about his journey and the
amazing growth and success
he's had.
And he's also going to share
with us his do's and his
don'ts.
Bob, thank you so much
for taking the time
to talk to us today.
Before we get started, tell
us a little bit about Geotab.
BOB BRADLEY: Hey, Bruno.
No problem.
Yeah, so Geotab is a world
leader in the telematics space.
And so really,
what that means is,
we have millions of
connected vehicles.
In fact, we have over
2 million connected
vehicles driving around with
our little device inside of them
around the world, and a
really, really dense population
of vehicles here in North
America and a large population
in Europe, Latin America.
And Geotab has been
expanding pretty rapidly
over the past few years.
And so it gives us a really,
really unique look at the world
we live in, from a
data perspective,
because this data is immensely
useful for fleet managers.
So they're using it to manage
where their vehicles go
and company operations.
But on aggregate, these
2 million vehicles
can tell us what the temperature
is on the side of the road
and whether a road is bumpy
in the middle of Europe
or in the middle of
the United States.
And we can learn an awful
lot about cities around us
and whether
intersections take longer
at certain times
of the day and what
traffic patterns look like.
And so over the past five
years that I've been at Geotab,
we've gone from about 400,000
of these connected devices
to somewhere in the
2.2-million neighborhood today.
And so that kind of growth
has been both amazing and a
challenge for us.
BRUNO AZIZA: And now, the data
that you collect, of course,
is 24/7.
It's real-time.
Tell us a little about
the volume there.
BOB BRADLEY: Yeah, the data
we collect-- you're right--
is real-time and 24/7.
Customers of Geotab range from
small mom-and-pop trucking
companies to emergency services.
So the data needs to
be correct and timely.
And so we're streaming this
data in every single day.
From a data and
analytics perspective,
that means about 40
billion points of data
that we get to play
with every single day.
And I think we're somewhere
in the neighborhood of 11
petabytes of data sitting
in Google BigQuery, which is
our data warehouse of choice.
BRUNO AZIZA: So we're definitely
talking about large data sets,
fast-moving data sets.
The products involved,
we're talking
about BigQuery, data flow,
real-time data, Cloud Composer.
Tell us a little bit
about the use cases,
specifically, that you're
using these products for.
BOB BRADLEY: Sure.
So our customers are monitoring
their fleets, their own fleets,
looking at their own operations.
But as a whole, if we can take
these 2.1 million vehicles,
and we can take this data
that's coming in at that pace,
and we can actually
run analytics on that,
there's a lot we
can learn and teach
our customers about their data.
So one of the use cases
that comes to mind
is, we had customers that
were telling us that battery
breakdowns were a big problem.
And so we have fleets
that are one vehicle,
but we also have fleets that
might be 100,000 vehicles.
And so if you scale up
roadside breakdowns,
the batteries themselves
aren't very expensive.
But when you're seeing 80%
of our on-road breakdowns
happen because of electrical
systems, it's not the battery.
It's not the part.
It's the sending of a tow truck.
It's the tow.
It's the sending of a
mechanic and the replacing
of these parts that become
very, very expensive.
And so we started a POC.
One of the things that
I really believe in
is getting customers
involved first
so we can really, truly
understand the customer
problem.
And so we thought, OK,
this particular customer
has a large fleet.
But in the 2.1 million vehicles,
there's tens of thousands
of other vehicles
that drive and operate
in similar conditions
with similar engine types.
What can we learn from
the group that we can then
help this customer
identify batteries
that potentially could fail?
And so we did a four-month POC
with a very, very large fleet.
And the goal was to reduce
these roadside breakdowns.
They're expensive.
Product doesn't get to the door.
SLAs are broken.
And I think there were some
learnings here as well.
I think our goal, on the
onset, was all to predict
a maintenance problem.
Everybody talks about
mean time to fail.
We need to tell this
customer, within three days,
your battery is going to fail.
And what we learned
through the short POC
was that that really wasn't
what we needed to do.
What we needed to do
was help this customer
with so many vehicles understand
which of their vehicles
are exhibiting
electrical-systems issues
and which of their vehicles
appear to have bad batteries
or don't look normal,
as it compares
to the rest of the 2.1
million vehicles that
operate like they do.
And so it was a pretty
successful little POC
that has now spun
into a core product
that we can offer to customers
in that we were able to reduce
their downtime by--
almost 25% of the roadside
downtime was reduced.
And there were little side
effects that we didn't expect.
We had almost 10%
of less labor costs,
because there weren't so many
surprise battery replacements
or electrical-systems tests
on the side of the road.
So it was a great little POC.
Of course, then the
problem becomes,
how do you scale from one
customer to many customers?
And I think, because we use
Google BigQuery and some
of those tools as our
core data warehouse,
and because that's where we
run a lot of our experiments,
the scaling issue becomes
nonexistent for us
as we scale up and we
just lean in on some
of that capacity that
is offered to us by some
of those products.
BRUNO AZIZA: And you have
been able to scale it,
as much innovation
as you put out here.
Actually, I think you
have about eight patents
on this particular--
BOB BRADLEY: Yeah.
BRUNO AZIZA: --use
case, as an outcome.
BOB BRADLEY: Yeah, there's
about eight patents
on that particular use case
right now, as an outcome.
And we're able to scale this
up and generalize the solution.
And we'll be rolling it
out live with-- it actually
took us about a year.
What makes us unique as
well, as a company, is,
since we manufacture
the hardware,
we're able to push out updates.
So it became a real team effort
at Geotab in that we actually
discovered new, novel
ways of recording some
of this information and
detecting changes to make
the product even better.
So it was a bit of
an iterative process
with the whole engineering
side of the company
to get this out there.
But yeah, scale has
never been the problem.
Ingesting the data
hasn't been a problem.
And running queries over the
data and models over the data
hasn't been a problem,
which really frees us
up, then, to work
hand-in-hand with customers
and really focusing on what the
actual mechanical problem is.
BRUNO AZIZA: So that's
quite an amazing journey,
starting with one customer
and then expanding
that to the rest of your
fleet and understanding
there's a million data points
at a time and with the outcome,
with an amazing recognition
for your innovation.
What have you learned
through the process here?
What are some of the
do's and don'ts here?
Maybe let's start with
the positive first.
What are some of
the things that are
the do's that everybody
here listening to us
should go out and do?
BOB BRADLEY: I think one thing
that taught us an awful lot--
and it had a waterfall
effect in lessons--
was engaging with customers
early in the process.
I've been with Geotab
for about five years,
and the data team was
quite small at the time.
And we've grown rapidly.
And those first few years were
really learning and exploring
and playing with the
data and with customers
to understand the value that
we could then derive out
of it in the years to come.
And so working with
customers closely and early
allowed us to start
conducting research
with a clear path to product.
So we weren't
conducting research
for the sake of research,
but with a clear path,
like an applied
research approach
where the outcome should
solve a business problem.
And really, the object
was to fail fast.
The four-month POC was one
of many four-month POCs.
And those other ones--
if we fail fast
and pivot, we can
get to a solution a
little bit quicker.
I think one of the biggest
learnings for any of us
engineers-- we wanted
to make these 99%--
like I said, mean time to fail--
99%-accurate models, when,
at the end of the day,
we're saving real money
and saving real downtime
for customers without
needing to be 99% accurate.
So I think it was a
lesson learned there
that 99% accurate on a problem
that nobody wants you to solve
is not a good approach.
Better to be reasonably accurate
on a large-scale problem that
can really help folks, and
then iterate on that problem
and bring up that accuracy.
BRUNO AZIZA: Yeah, it's the
idea around being directionally
right and then improving
on that results
rather than just trying
to be right and imperfect
rather than be done.
What about the opposite of that?
What are some of the
mistakes that you
think people listening to us
should look out for and try
to avoid, even though they
are the result of things
that might have been common
sense in the first place?
BOB BRADLEY: I've
said this before.
I think I've said it
at some of your offices
doing a small talk.
One of the best things about,
say, a product like Google
BigQuery is that
it's very, very easy
to get your data into Google
BigQuery and move it around.
And one of the worst things
about Google BigQuery
is that it's very,
very easy to get
your data into Google BigQuery.
And one of the things
that Geotab did early on
was, we started
pushing as much data
as we could into
Google BigQuery.
So it's not just
the vehicle data.
It's operational data.
It's all of our server
metrics, application logs.
That really, really
helps us triage a problem
from beginning to end.
So definitely would not
change how we did that.
But in doing so, you can't lag
data governance and DataOps
far behind, because you end up
with multiple sources of ground
truth or disparate data
sets that are trying
to answer the same problem.
And so I think with that ease
of use and ease of getting data
into BigQuery came some
hiccups along the way,
where, we need to now clean
up some of those resources,
and we need to figure
out which of A and B
is ground truth to
solve this problem.
So those data silos can
happen pretty quickly.
BRUNO AZIZA: Yeah, and
they can cost you a lot--
BOB BRADLEY: Yeah.
BRUNO AZIZA: --down the line.
Did you have to hire
different types of folks
to make sure that
you'd managed for that?
How did you build
it into the process?
BOB BRADLEY: Yeah, over time,
I think we started out heavy
on the science and analyst
side of things, because we have
so many managed services that
we leverage from you guys.
But over time, we started to
pick up many, many more data
engineers and folks
that are focused
on pipelines and best practices,
data governance, and data
operations.
So yeah, I think there was
a fundamental shift there.
What was amazing
about it, as I said,
those first few years
that I spent at Geotab
were a lot of experimentation
and a lot of playing.
And we didn't have to worry
about the overhead of pipelines
and things like that.
But now as things
become mature products,
we need to make sure
that those pipelines run,
that there's monitoring and SLAs
and all of those fun things.
And I think that we played
catch-up a little bit there.
BRUNO AZIZA: That's
outstanding, Bob.
Thank you so much for sharing
these lessons with us today.
I learned a lot about,
building better products means
engaging with customers early.
And in your case, you
learned from one customer
and scaled it to
the rest of them.
So it's really quite amazing.
Eight patents, an
incredible story there.
And then the don't
is, don't wait
to implement DataOps and
data governance early, maybe
through data engineers
that you might
want to hire or a change in your
process, so you can avoid data
silos, because
they could cost you
a lot throughout the journey.
Again, like I said, thanks
for giving us the time today.
I hope many people are
going to reach out to you
and connect with you.
They've got a lot to
learn from Geotab.
We appreciate your time,
and we appreciate you
being a great partner of ours.
We'll talk to you soon.
BOB BRADLEY: No problem.
Thanks, Bruno.
[MUSIC PLAYING]